- [Instructor] Free
energy is symbolized by G.
And the change in free energy is delta G.
When there's a subscript of F,
this is talking about the change
in the free energy of formation.
Which refers to the
change in the free energy
for the formation of
one mole of a substance
from its elements in
their standard states.
These superscript naught
refers to the fact
that the substances are
in their standard states.
By convention, the standard change
in free energy of formation for an element
and its standard state is equal to zero.
Therefore, if we think about
forming one mole of oxygen gas,
we would be making it
from elemental oxygen
which is also oxygen gas.
So forming one mole of
oxygen gas from one mole
of oxygen gas means
there will be no change
and therefore the standard change
in free energy of
formation is equal to zero.
Textbooks often tabulate
data for standard change
in free energy of formation of substances
at 25 degrees Celsius.
However, it doesn't have
to be that temperature.
The units are in kilojoules per mole.
We've already seen that
the standard change
in free energy of formation for an element
is equal to zero.
Therefore for elemental
oxygen, O2 delta G naught
is equal to zero.
And for carbon in the solid
state in the form of graphite,
delta G naught is also equal to zero.
The value for carbon monoxide
is naught equal to zero.
Delta G naught is equal
to negative 137.2 kilojoules per mole.
So if we think about forming
one mole of carbon monoxide
from its elements,
carbon monoxide is composed
of carbon and oxygen.
And the elemental form of oxygen is O2 gas
and the elements of form of carbon
is the solid form in graphite.
So this value for the standard change
in free energy of formation
of carbon monoxide is talking
about the change in free
energy for the formation
of one mole of carbon
monoxide from its elements
in their standard states.
Standard changes in free energy
of formation of substances
are useful because they
can be used to calculate
the standard change in free
energy for a chemical reaction.
The standard change in free
energy of a chemical reaction
is equal to the sum of the standard change
in free energy of formation
of the products and from that
you subtract the sum
of the standard change
in free energy of
formation of the reactants.
For our reaction,
let's look at these
synthesis of ammonia gas
from nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas.
Our goal is to calculate the
standard change in free energy
for this reaction at 25 degrees Celsius.
First, we need to think
about our products.
For this reaction,
we have only one product
and that's ammonia.
Notice how there's a two as a coefficient
in front of ammonia and
the balanced equation.
So we would need to look
up the standard change
in free energy of formation of ammonia
at 25 degrees Celsius.
And because this value
is per mole of ammonia,
we would need to multiply it by two
because we have two moles
in our balanced equation.
Next, we think about our reactants.
And we have two reactants,
nitrogen and hydrogen.
And we need the sum of
their standard changes
in free energy of formation.
So we would write the standard change
in free energy of formation of nitrogen.
And because there's a one
in our balanced equation,
we multiply that value by
one and two that we add
the standard change in
free energy of formation
of hydrogen gas.
And since we have a three
in our balanced equation,
we would multiply that by three.
So going back to ammonia,
the standard change in
free energy of formation
is equal to negative
16.5 kilojoules per mole,
multiply that by two moles
and the moles will cancel out.
For nitrogen and hydrogen,
those are both elements
in their standard states
and therefore their standard
free energy of formations
are equal to zero.
So this is just zero plus zero.
So the standard change in
free energy for this reaction
is equal to negative 33.0
kilojoules at 25 degrees Celsius.
Standard state for a gas
refers to the pure gas
at a pressure of one atmosphere.
So we think about all three of our gases
at a partial pressure of one atmosphere
at a temperature of 25 degrees Celsius.
The standard change and free
energy for this reaction
is negative 33.0 kilojoules.
Since the change in
free energy is negative,
that tells us the reaction as
thermodynamically favorable
in the forward direction.
So nitrogen and hydrogen
will react together
to form more ammonia.
Textbooks often give
the units as kilojoules
for the standard change and free energy
of a chemical reaction.
However, sometimes you
also see kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Per mole of reaction simply refers
to how the balanced equation is written.
And here we have the formation
of two moles of ammonia.
So we can write a conversion
factor of two moles
of ammonia per one mole of reaction.
For standard free energies of formation,
the units are kilojoules
per mole of the substance.
So in this case,
it's negative 16.5 kilojoules
per mole of ammonia.
So moles of ammonia would cancel out,
which gives kilojoules per
mole of reaction for the units.